Trascrizione: Nicola Storgato
Revisore: Martina Abrami
Lo sapete che al mondo
ci sono più smartphone che persone?
Nulla di nuovo.
Oggi questi dispositivi
sono diventati ormai fondamentali
per la nostra vita quotidiana.
Eppure, vi siete mai fermati un secondo
a pensare a qual è
il loro vero potenziale?
Oggi sappiamo che gli smartphone non sono
solo dei dispositivi di comunicazione.
Sono dei dispositivi che registrano
le informazioni in maniera incessante,
raccogliendo dati
che sono riflesso diretto
di chi siamo e di come
interagiamo con il mondo.
Ma per capire a pieno il loro potenziale,
dobbiamo focalizzarci
su due elementi chiave.
Il primo sono i dati, appunto.
Quando utilizziamo lo smartphone
produciamo una miriade di informazioni:
dalle nostre ricerche online
alle applicazioni che usiamo,
ai luoghi che visitiamo.
Ma se per esempio andiamo
a fare una corsa,
grazie allo smartphone
o gli orologi sportivi,
possiamo misurare cose
come il tempo della corsa,
la distanza e il battito cardiaco.
Tutto questo diventa una sequenza
di dati pronti a essere generati.
Però i dati, per quanto importanti,
hanno bisogno di una struttura,
di un contesto.
E qui entra in gioco
l’elemento chiave, il numero due.
I modelli.
Quando utilizziamo lo smartphone
e guardiamo il meteo, per esempio,
non stiamo accedendo a dei dati
da delle stazioni meteorologiche.
Stiamo interagendo
con dei modelli matematici e fisici,
che hanno analizzato questi dati per noi
e per la nostra specifica posizione.
Quindi, se torniamo
all’esempio della corsa,
in base ai dati che abbiamo generato,
il modello ci potrà fare una stima
di quelle che sono le calorie
che abbiamo bruciato.
Se prendiamo dati e modelli
e creiamo un flusso continuo,
possiamo dare vita a quella
che in matematica è definita
assimilazione dei dati.
Non è più un evento isolato,
ma è appunto un flusso
continuo di informazioni.
Grazie a queste informazioni, quindi,
raccogliamo i dati
e aggiorniamo il modello.
Questo concetto è molto importante
perché ci porta al tema della previsione,
cioè quella capacità di prevedere
comportamenti o eventi
sulla base dell’analisi
di dati passati e presenti.
Questo sta alla base
della ricerca scientifica.
Molti scienziati nel mondo
spendono il loro tempo
a cercare di comprendere
fenomeni fisici, meccanici, biologici
e da lì si cerca, quindi,
di creare un modello,
che ci aiuti a capire
e a prevedere il comportamento.
Quindi, se torniamo
all’esempio della corsa,
in base ai dati che abbiamo generato
e in base al modello che abbiamo,
possiamo fare una previsione
su quello che è il carico di allenamento
che dobbiamo sostenere
se vogliamo prepararci
a correre una maratona in quattro ore.
È cosa è molto importante,
usata anche nei sistemi ingegneristici.
E la storia è sempre la stessa.
Abbiamo dei dati, la cui qualità
e quantità aumenta ogni giorno
e abbiamo dei modelli,
che sono soprattutto basati sulla fisica,
cioè su quelle leggi e su quelle equazioni
che regolano e descrivono
le leggi della natura.
Se prendiamo dati e modelli,
possiamo quindi creare
un cosiddetto modello personalizzato.
E oggi questi modelli personalizzati
hanno un nome ben preciso:
digital twins o gemelli digitali.
Ma cos’è, appunto, un digital twin?
È un modello personalizzato
che evolve dinamicamente.
Se, per esempio, prendiamo un aereo,
abbiamo l’aereo che è il gemello fisico
e abbiamo il suo gemello digitale.
Se prendiamo i dati a bordo dell’aereo
possiamo informare il gemello digitale
e utilizzando i dati
di navigazione di ogni volo,
possiamo formare il gemello digitale
in maniera continua e dinamica.
È molto importante perché non sto creando
un modello generico.
Sto creando un modello
specifico di quell’aereo
che sta in questo momento
viaggiando da Treviso a Parigi.
Ma qual è il vantaggio di tutto ciò?
I gemelli digitali hanno la capacità
di prevedere problemi
prima che si verifichino.
Inoltre possono fornire
una manutenzione mirata,
piuttosto che basata
su delle stime generiche.
In questo modo, il gemello digitale
potrà seguire la vita dell’aereo
durante tutte le sue fasi.
Quando invecchia,
si deteriora e viene riparato.
Questo concetto è utilizzato
attualmente in varie parti,
ma si pensa che questo concetto
sia stato introdotto per la prima volta
nel 2010 da un rapporto della NASA.
Ma questa idea di modello digitale
che evolve dinamicamente
sembra sia stata introdotta ben prima.
In molti reputano
il programma Apollo della NASA
come il luogo dove questi digital twin
sono stati introdotti per la prima volta.
Negli anni 60 e 70,
durante il programma Apollo della NASA,
vi furono le missioni Apollo
e contemporaneamente
venne sviluppato un simulatore a terra,
a Houston, per seguire la missione.
Questo simulatore si è rivelato
particolarmente importante
durante la missione Apollo 13
e probabilmente alcuni di voi
conoscono la storia
perché hanno visto il film
"Apollo 13" con Tom Hanks.
In quella missione vi furono
dei danneggiamenti nell'astronave
che misero in serio repentaglio
la vita dei tre astronauti a bordo.
In quella situazione, la NASA decise
di prendere i dati dal gemello fisico,
quindi, l’astronave bloccata nello spazio,
e di trasferirli nel gemello digitale,
il simulatore a terra.
In questo modo, ha potuto fare
un'assimilazione dei dati
e da lì avere una rappresentazione
dell’astronave danneggiata.
Inoltre, è stato possibile fare previsioni
che hanno poi facilitato le decisioni
per riportare a casa
gli astronauti sani e salvi.
Ora, dopo più di 50 anni,
stiamo riutilizzando lo stesso concetto,
ma lo stiamo espandendo ben oltre
il settore aerospaziale.
Stiamo iniziando a vedere
digital twin per ponti,
per infrastrutture civili,
per parchi eolici
e per l’efficienza energetica
degli edifici.
Anche nel mondo medico
c’è un grosso interesse
nella creazione di digital twin,
soprattutto per quanto riguarda
la diagnosi
e il trattamento personalizzato.
Ora, probabilmente, alcuni di voi
si stanno chiedendo:
“Qual è il collegamento
fra i digital twin e i terremoti?”
Per fare ciò dobbiamo innanzitutto
fare un passo indietro e chiederci:
“Cos’è un terremoto?”
Il terremoto è uno scorrimento che avviene
lungo una frattura della terra,
le cosiddette faglie tettoniche.
Durante questo scorrimento viene
rilasciata un’enorme quantità di energia,
sotto forma di onde sismiche.
Queste onde sismiche poi provocano
la scossa sotto i nostri piedi.
Questa energia proviene
dalla tettonica a placche.
Le placche tettoniche della Terra
si spostano continuamente,
ma molto lentamente
con tassi che sono di pochi millimetri
o pochi centimetri all’anno.
Questo fa sì che lo stress pian pianino
si accumuli lungo queste faglie
e quando lo stress supera
la resistenza della roccia,
queste faglie iniziano a scorrere,
creando il terremoto.
Questi eventi sono catastrofici
per certi versi,
perché mentre il caricamento può avvenire
in vari decenni, addirittura secoli,
il rilascio dell’energia in un terremoto
può avvenire in pochi secondi.
Il risultato è devastante.
Le faglie tettoniche
sono in grado di spostarsi
di diversi metri in pochi secondi,
mentre la frattura propaga a una velocità
che è di tre 3 o 4 chilometri al secondo.
Pensate che negli ultimi vent’anni,
più di 800.000 persone
hanno perso la vita a causa dei terremoti,
rendendo questo evento
uno dei più devastanti a livello naturale.
Inoltre ci fa riflettere sull’impatto
che i terremoti hanno sulla vita umana
e ci fa pensare alla vulnerabilità umana
di fronte a questi eventi naturali.
Sappiamo dove si trovano
le faglie più attive oggigiorno,
dove c’è il maggiore rischio sismico.
Tuttavia, prevedere quando e dove
avverrà il prossimo terremoto,
quella è un’impresa ben più ardua.
Il motivo è tanto semplice
quanto complesso.
Ogni faglia ha la sua storia,
un suo comportamento
e delle caratteristiche uniche.
Un po’ come l’esempio
del ponte o dell’aereo,
o della persona che si sta preparando
a correre una maratona.
Ognuno di noi ha la propria storia.
Quindi se pensiamo ai terremoti,
sappiamo che ci sono certe faglie
che si spostano più di frequente,
rilasciando l’energia in piccole dosi.
Altre invece, possono rimanere
silenziose per diversi decenni
per poi rilasciare l’energia
in un unico devastante momento.
Sappiamo che le caratteristiche geologiche
e la presenza di fluidi
possono controllare come e dove
avviene un terremoto.
È una cosa importante da considerare
perché nonostante i passi avanti fatti,
la sismologia è riuscita a mappare faglie
e analizzare eventi del passato.
Ha messo in evidenza
che ci sono delle variabili
come pressione, temperatura
e sforzo nella crosta,
che rendono la previsione precisa
un’impresa titanica.
Tuttavia, stiamo vivendo una vera
e propria rivoluzione tecnologica,
dato che abbiamo
una capacità senza precedenti
di raccogliere dati e anche di elaborarli.
Oggi, nella penisola italiana abbiamo
una distribuzione di sensori sismici
che possono misurare i dati
di sismicità, quindi i terremoti,
e lo spostamento di queste faglie.
Ma questi dati, come tutti i dati,
hanno bisogno di una struttura,
di un contesto e, quindi, di un modello.
E dato che ogni faglia ha la sua storia,
abbiamo bisogno
di un modello personalizzato.
Ecco dove entrano in gioco i digital twin.
Immaginate per un secondo
un modello digitale della terra
e di una faglia ben specifica,
che può raccogliere dati
e aggiornarsi in tempo reale.
Ma tutto questo
è possibile farlo veramente?
O è solo pura immaginazione?
La realtà dei fatti è che creare
un digital twin per i terremoti
non è così facile.
Ci sono scale di tempo molto variabili,
dai periodi di caricamento delle faglie,
che possono durare vari decenni,
ai periodi che intercorrono
durante il terremoto,
la gestione dell’emergenza
e le scosse di assestamento.
Tuttavia, non siamo
così distanti dalla realtà.
Oggi sappiamo che questo è possibile.
L’Unione europea ha finanziato un progetto
per creare il primo
digital twin per i terremoti.
Questo progetto si chiama DT-GEO
e sfruttando il potenziale
dei gemelli digitali,
vogliamo creare un sistema in grado
di monitorare, interpretare e valutare
il rischio sismico
in maniera continua e dinamica.
Per fare ciò dobbiamo concentrarci
su quello che avviene
sia prima che dopo un terremoto.
Prima di un terremoto vogliamo analizzare
la sismicità storica
di un determinato luogo
e utilizzare simulazioni al computer
per capire quello che potrebbe succedere
nell’eventualità di un grande terremoto.
Inoltre, vogliamo analizzare
i dati di spostamento a terra
grazie ai dati satellitari o i dati GPS,
simili a quelli che avete
nel vostro smartphone,
e da lì capire dove
si concentra questo stress.
Inoltre, utilizzare i dati di sismicità.
Non solo quando avvengono
i grandi terremoti,
ma anche quelli più piccoli,
che però ci danno un’informazione su dove
si sta concentrando questa deformazione.
Pensate che in Italia vengono registrati
più di 16.000 terremoti all’anno.
Siamo quasi a 44 terremoti al giorno
e circa uno ogni mezz'ora.
E poi quello che avviene subito,
durante e dopo un terremoto.
Nei sistemi di allerta precoce
nel nostro smartphone,
che ci consentono di ricevere
un preavviso, un allarme,
pochi secondi prima che arrivi la scossa.
Alla gestione dell’emergenza,
soprattutto quando vogliamo guidare
la Protezione civile
in quelle aree colpite dal terremoto
e che perdono momentaneamente
la connessione con il mondo esterno.
E infine, la gestione
e l’analisi della sismicità
per capire la probabilità che si possano
venire a creare scosse di assestamento.
Questo sistema non risolverà
il problema di fondo,
che è quello di prevedere i terremoti,
ma ci aiuterà a creare un sistema
che sia in grado di gestire
meglio una crisi sismica.
In particolar modo, in quelle situazioni
in cui ogni minuto, ogni ora,
possono essere cruciali
per salvare vite umane.
Il progetto DT-GEO
è il primo progetto al mondo
che vuole creare un digital twin
per i terremoti.
In realtà, serviranno anni
per creare un sistema validato
che possa essere poi utilizzato
in tutto il mondo.
Ma per creare il primo digital twin
per i terremoti,
il prototipo da utilizzare in futuro,
abbiamo deciso di farlo nel Bedretto Lab,
un laboratorio sotterraneo
nel cuore delle Alpi svizzere.
Questo laboratorio è gestito dall’ETH,
il Politecnico federale
di Zurigo, in Svizzera,
e ci consente di fare
attività sperimentali
vicino a delle faglie tettoniche,
dato che si trova a un chilometro
e mezzo di profondità
in un tunnel che è lungo
circa cinque chilometri.
In questo modo,
possiamo fare attività sperimentali
andando a iniettare fluidi nella roccia.
In questo modo,
fare delle stimolazioni idrauliche
che consentono di perturbare
lo stress nella roccia.
In questo modo, innescare
dei piccoli terremoti controllati.
Terremoti molto piccoli, con una magnitudo
di 0,1 o fino a magnitudo 1,
impercettibili per le persone,
ma estremamente importanti per noi,
per testare tecnologie e sensori
che ci aiutino a capire
come queste faglie si comportano
prima, durante e dopo un terremoto.
E da lì creare un modello personalizzato,
un digital twin, appunto.
E in questo percorso
di scoperta e innovazione,
dobbiamo sempre chiederci:
“Quale eredità vogliamo lasciare
alle generazioni future?”
I digital twin, con le loro potenzialità,
non rappresentano solo un passo in avanti
nel modo in cui interagiamo
con i nostri dispositivi,
come gli smartphone,
o i fenomeni naturali, come i terremoti.
Ma anche un impegno a creare
un futuro più sicuro e informato.
E in questo percorso
di scoperta e innovazione,
ogni passo che facciamo non è solo
un avanzamento tecnologico e scientifico,
ma è anche un piccolo mattoncino
dell’eredità che vogliamo
lasciare al futuro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)